Hey youtubers it’s charlie, welcome to my
game of thrones season 4 preview for Varys.
If you’ve seen my other previews you know
I’m picking some of our favorite characters
big and small and talking about what they’ll
be doing in season 4.
As always, spoilers for everything in seasons
1 through 3, and partial spoilers for books
4 and 5.
I really feel like Game of Thrones the tv
show kind of buries the lead, but Varys is
the spider of Kings Landing.
Like Pycelle, he appears really non-threatening
but in the creepiest possible ways.
But during season 3 we actually learned that
Varys is all about the long con.
So lets talk about what his true goal is,
what he’s going to do about it in season
4 and what his motivations are.
Number 1: Varys is trying to restore the Targaryen’s
to the Throne.
We learned this in season 1 when arya caught
him plotting with Illyrio.
Why?
He is extremely well read and has learned
about the dangers of the white walkers and
the great other.
He really does want Westeros to survive and
they can only do it united.
So the war of the 5 kings has to end and he
feels like someone from the Targaryen Bloodline
is the best person to lead them.
Dany is obviously at the top of that list,
but there are a few other worthy bastards
like Gendry and Jon Snow who look like they
have leadership potential.
I’ll talk more about the other contenders
for the throne later.
Number 2: During Season 4, Varys is going
to take steps to eliminate threats to his
vision of a Targaryen restoration.
Since he’s the spider of westeros, you’ll
never see vary’s carve someone up or crossbow
them to death.
Varys real skill is in creating the circumstances
for his plans to unfold without having to
really do anything.
So other characters will do things that get
rid of contenders for the throne.
Recently George RR Martin talked about the
Purple Wedding in an interview and while I
don’t want to spoil it too much, Varys basically
enables everything that happens during it
and helps during the aftermath.
For people that have read the books and know
what’s happening already, think about it
this way.
Varys already knows everything that happened
and who was responsible, but because he’s
trying to restore the targaryens he kind of
lets things happen in a roundabout way so
that two birds are killed with one stone.
Well it’s not a stone that does the job,
but you get the idea.
(b/w)
Number 3: Why is he doing all of this?
He’s from the eastern kingdoms so he’s
not trying to avenge his bloodline and he’s
not in love with any of the ruling houses.
And I’ll even go so far as to say that even
though he’s trying to restore them, he’s
not in love with any of the targaryens.
His real motivation is that he hates magic
of any kind.
In that season 3 scene with tyrion where he
talks about patience and revenge he explains
exactly why he hates magic.
Because he understands what a threat it is.
Under normal circumstances he was able to
grow his influence in the really classic sense
of the American Dream.
But if say a magical army of zombies were
to take over the world.
Everyone would die.
So for Vary’s is more about the devil you
know.
Originally he had intended for Dany’s older
brother Rhaegar to take the throne and based
on what the books have told us about him,
he would have been the great leader Varys
had wanted.
But like everything on game of thrones, his
plans went to shit when Aerys killed Rickard
and Brandon stark and the rest of the great
houses joined Robert’s rebellion.
It wasn’t really Rhaegar kidnapping Lyanna,
if that’s actually what happened (there
are rumors that there was something else going
on there.
like a lovechild name snow).
It was really the murder of the starks that
dumped the gasoline on the fire.
So now that we know Varys is going to be taking
some more direct steps to restore Dany to
the throne in season 4 let me know what you
think he’ll end up doing.
Is he going to try and have Littlefinger killed?
What is he going to do about mad King Joffrey?
Since so many of you have requested her next,
I’m going to make Cersei my next Season
4 video.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
I’ll try and post that on Monday.
In the meantime, I finally hit 25 thousand
subscribers officially and wanted to say thank
you again.
I’ve gotten contact info for all the winners
of my sherlock giveaway and I’ll be mailing
you your stuff this week.
In the meantime you can check out my other
Season 4 videos by clicking here and you can
check out my Legend of Korra Season 2 videos
by clicking here.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow
high fives!